this is the moment afghan refugees were
first greeted by officials in mexico
city on tuesday night their arrival
follows what mexican authorities have
described as a difficult journey across
six countries
in the pre-dawn hours of wednesday a
second flight arrived with more than 100
other afghan nationals many of them
journalists and other media workers
seeking refuge in mexico all of whom
were welcomed personally by mexican
foreign minister marcelo
we might be very far away from what is
happening in afghanistan but the human
cause the protection of the values that
we identify with as mexicans have led to
a commitment from us so they can be in
mexico
when it comes to rolling out the welcome
mat for refugees mexico has a long
tradition
historically mexico has been a top
destination especially for people who
are fleeing political situations as was
the case with chile argentina and spain
mexico has always been an important and
welcoming nation
across mexico many are expecting the
country will welcome more afghan
families in the days ahead
shelters like this one near the
outskirts of mexico city say their doors
are open to anyone seeking a safe space
and a meal
we don't discriminate if people want to
come from afghanistan or anywhere else
they'll be well received
the arrival of refugees from afghanistan
also spotlights how mexico is already
hosting a growing number of displaced
people from around the world who are
seeking asylum
so far this year mexican officials have
recorded more than 64 thousand asylum
applications and data suggests that 2021
is on pace to set a new record for the
number of people seeking asylum in the
country
some experts have warned that mexico's
ability to care for everyone may be
limited due to the growing populations
of migrants and refugees fleeing crises
in haiti venezuela and countries in
central america
mexico is one of only a handful of latin
american countries including chile and
costa rica that have offered a
commitment to aiding refugees from
afghanistan
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city